my husband and I we've been together for
20 years never done a puzzle together we
did a puzzle we loved it my wife
suggested that it was looking a little
ratty and she thought that if I was
gonna be on TV and she likes the beard
she finds it attractive but she thought
it was a little unyielding so I went
upstairs and I had but the little
trimmer that I had has like a grater
kind of like clippers I was just going
to take it down but I taking a big so
awesome
pascale Cavan it's so nice to see your
faces it's unfortunate that it's under
these circumstances I wish I could hug
both of you how are you guys doing
during this very strange time well I
mean we're over a month in I feel like I
kind of found my groove now and now like
the homeschooling thing is well underway
and that is that is no joke it's back
and I have question monopolizing most my
time and I think how lucky I am like we
never were really supposed to be working
at this time like when calls the heart
wraps before Christmas and then this is
always kind of like our hiatus time and
so I feel very blessed that I have the
time and attention to be able to just
invest in my kids I would also say that
what's in a you and I Pascal and I've
talked about this and touched on this
briefly that I mean obviously it's kind
of scary and a lot of people are going
through some some sad times with you
know lost loved ones and things like
that and you know businesses are
impacted and it's it's obviously a
terrible thing at the same time I feel
like somehow it's kind of been a gift
because I've kind of got this time with
my kids my my eldest is 12 my youngest
is nine and I know I'm jumping the gun
here but they're gonna leave home fairly
soon and I feel like I'm getting this
giant compressed vacation time with them
and it's
I'm so thankful for it I can't it just I
know I should be you know scared and
upset but I can't help but just thinking
every morning I'm like you get that hang
with my wife and my kids today and it's
a weak culture of you to find a silver
lining in all of this it's gin that part
is genuine I'm not much likely Coulter
but in that particular respect I am I
really feel it's been an absolute boon
to be able to get this time Kevin and I
both have been talking about this
throughout that throat the quarantine is
just they have no one else they have
each other and that's it and it's just
been so beautiful to see that friendship
and brotherly connection just like cloth
bake-off
if I can ask where are you guys where
are you quarantine and who are you hold
up with so we're on at my home in
Vancouver and it's just my two kids and
me and my husband and our nanny lives
with us so she's with us as well I'm
actually on my own shot I want my own
shot how meny is it good I'm at home to
set up with my kids my kids I know
scallops husband is continuing to work
but my wife and I are here together all
the time yeah there is good and bad with
that okay so that leads me to my next
question you know we all love each other
it's always kumbaya but this is this is
brand-new circumstances we are all
together 24/7 so how are things going at
home
are there any bickerings or corals going
on or is everyone kind of keeping the
peace keV
okay
well I think both of us are gonna pretty
much say more or less the same thing
we're very lucky that we picked the
right people yes my wife and I bicker at
the best of times and there's certainly
no shortage of that right now but we
also are and always had been very much
in love so this hasn't been monumental I
think my wife more than I I'm kind of
more of a homebody than she is anyway a
little more antisocial maybe she's quite
social and quite gregarious oh I think
it's been a bit harder on her
she misses getting away from me we do to
date nights a week now two nights will
we make a special dinner and have a
bottle of wine and sit by the fire just
kind of talk about the week so tonight
is kids do when you are they a part of
it or are they okay we're gonna go deep
I'll go deep my question absolutely I
want okay so I was gonna come up with a
joke but the truth is I'm pretty strict
when it comes to video games and stuff I
don't like it it's not I don't think
it's good for my kids really but two
nights a week
what will let them play a little
excessively so after dinner we'll do
dinner together everybody plays they
make sure to get tons exercise during
the day and then you know what about
7:00 7:30 my wife and I will open a
bottle of wine but the fires start
talking and we'll let them play video
games for a couple hours just to stay on
are there that's a good a good deal yeah
yeah everybody wins there everybody wins
okay Pascal it's your turn tell me how
are things going at home they're going
they're going great I mean the bottom
line is they're going great we have a we
have an added pressure in our family my
husband's a first responder he's a
police officer so he's out like he's um
he's just out there and that obviously
as a family unit that ups our exposure
or potential exposure and makes his job
more stressful and makes it you know
more stressful for all of us just
thinking about that I'm more for the two
of us I
we don't put that on the kids or the
kids don't take that on at all um so
yeah so that's kind of a unique
situation that we deal with on a regular
daily basis I try and take on the bulk
of the homeschooling and because I'm the
one who's here all the time and and then
when he's home it's it's really mostly
about connecting as a family and just
making our family and the home life as
calm and peaceful and joyful well please
thank him for his service is so
important to have you know brave people
on the front lines like your husband and
and this conversation will will get more
lighthearted but I do have to ask what
has been most challenging about this
time for you to build for me with hands
down the hardest thing has been not
knowing how long it's going on for I
feel like if somebody had said to me if
somebody said to me even now if they
were like Pascal you're gonna be in
lockdown and you won't get to do any of
the things that you normally do but
it'll it'll only be until the end of
June but I think I could fix my brain on
that and I could kind of like almost
like a marathon right you can kind of
set that as your goal and pace yourself
and go that but to know that like I
don't know when the end is gonna be I
don't know when things will be back to
normal and no one obviously can give any
sort of answer to that that's been the
hardest thing and I really just have to
breathe through that and let that go
hang in there we're all in this together
exactly yeah cabin what's been the
hardest part about this for you and your
family I think that the hardest part for
me on this one
is that my kids and I have a very open
communication center but they ask me
anything they're not afraid to ask
questions about anything and I'll talk
about anything and I always sort of
champion that but I don't have the
answers right now so I'm having a hard
time trying to fill them with positivity
when I don't always know the answers and
I don't want to be wrong and I don't
want to set them up with the wrong
answer so I feel like what are they
asking you well they ask me things like
dad are we going back to school dad are
we going back to school in September am
I ever
and then my son asked me the other day
he goes dad when I start dating am I
allowed to hold hands first of all no
[Laughter]
and you would have just declare about
you have two boys I have two boys and
they're 12 and 9 woven ax and then
Pascal we love to see your two boys in
the video that you submitted earlier too
easy most of the stroll through the deep
dark wood a fox saw the mouse in the
most look good hell today two boys four
and eight okay so a little more of a
challenge for you go for a night there
for nine sorry blue doesn't really do a
lot of parenting did you have a birthday
in quarantine
next week actually cabins big birthday
next week 3303 well now I'm just full of
questions do you have a birthday
celebration are you gonna do a huge zoo
with all your relatives around well we
were going on a trip so we were supposed
to be filming our movie and our movie
was going to in Hawaii and our movie was
gonna finish right before his birthday
and we were gonna have this big
celebration
Aaron was gonna fly out for it our
families were gonna fly out for it we
were gonna have a big 50th like not
surprised birthday party for cabin in
Hawaii who's gonna be
did you want me to put on my hula skirt
yes we're good
yeah get your virtual backdrop going but
on the rulers but this time
be really I imagine it's somewhat of an
added challenge having you know kids
that are a little younger than cabins
how do you explain to them what's going
on are they asking you questions ah the
little one no he's living his best life
he actually said to me the other day he
was like I love Corona he goes I love
Corona I came like brother hole with me
all day every day like for him this is
like his best life his older brother is
his hero his like best friend
no one he'd rather be with and so tap
him home and they're together like this
is his best life the older one initially
when it was like you're not going back
to school because when when bank when
things kind of first hit in Vancouver it
was right at the beginning of the kids
spring break and so it was like they
went away on spring break and then it
was like and you're not going back and
so he was kind of like mmm and I said
don't worry like we're gonna figure
something out at home and at that point
schools didn't even know like what was
gonna happen or like how it was gonna
work
so I said don't worry like I'm gonna
take it on and he was like um I'm a
little concerned about that mama you are
not a qualified teacher and I was like
well I'm like bad and don't worry it's
gonna be fun doing a lot of like lesson
plans and like coming up with like ideas
that don't involve just like using this
math app and this reading app and this
app and this happened this happened I
just don't like it and so um anyways
it's a lot of work for me but I don't
mind it and he loves it and then with my
little one I kind of just um he kind of
pops in an off side you're good your own
plans yes I kind of put out things for
him but you know as for me preschool
it's like yeah
often they opt out whatever I don't care
like you know like you're good havin
how's virtual school going at your house
are you cracking open the algebra books
are you taking a front and center role
in all of this are you dividing with
your wife it's probably a
divide-and-conquer thing we my kids go
to French school so everything is in
French and my wife doesn't speak French
so that's what's up puts a lot of onus
on me but they have done very well and
she's great at all the tech stuff and I
am a straight-up [ __ ] when it comes to
this she does all the tech stuff I do
all the okay so let's talk let's talk
some happier hopefully more fun things
well I want to know what you not just as
mom and dad but as Pascal and cabin what
has been giving you joy during this time
have there been TV shows that you're
bingeing or I know Kevin you're always
in the kitchen what is it that you guys
have been doing you know well I've been
cooking a lot as I think every parent
out there is saying they're like oh my
gosh I'm always preparing food and so
yeah restaurants yes yeah but you know I
don't mind it I like it I like I like
being in the kitchen I like cooking
I've been reading quite a bit actually
the last mrs. Parrish have you any
either of you guys read that hmm oh it's
one of Reese Witherspoon's books I think
like for her book club uh-huh it's it's
like a light page-turner the other thing
this is the big excitement can't wait
for you to hear this Kevin I'm listening
so couldn't believe it my husband and I
we've been together for 20 years or over
20 years I think somewhere around there
never done a puzzle together we did a
puzzle we loved it
we sat there tooling away our little
puzzle together chit-chatting you know
that's what they do in old folks homes
you know I just placed an order I just
ordered like five more puzzles and
makitas
because we just did a 500 and we wanted
to tear our hair out it was worthless
ours was 550 that's what we like kind of
like ventured in on and it was not an
inspiring puzzle it was the only one we
had in house it was one my dad had given
us for Christmas I want to say like five
years ago it was still in the packaging
we've never opened it yeah we opened it
it was doorknobs literally it was the
puzzle was doorknobs it was from Lee
Valley tools right and so it was not an
in spot an inspiring
I've now ordered a bunch of like really
fun ones so I can't wait to tackle those
and those are I think I ordered one more
500 and then no foul juice tooth what mm
piece puzzle like they only have a
thousand I don't think I want to go over
a thousand but what they will do what
happen you know what I will give you
guys an update I'm gonna send you a
photo of that thousand-piece puzzle once
it's done graphic pascal's puzzles start
your new Instagram series I love it
Kevin what are you doing have you guys
finished anything I know obviously lots
of cooking right lots of cooking no
puzzles too much cooking
really I've enjoyed bread a lot of bread
but I've always made bread I've always
made bread but now I'm here because we
can't go to the grocery store so I'm
making bread a lot I like making bread
are you growing your yeast are you doing
yeah you are I knew it of course the
only way to go it's real it's good it's
healthy that way it's it's good healthy
yeast and the bread is so it's just so
much better are you doing any bread up
off social distance bread drop-offs
no no you watch Tiger King Kevin McGarry
had a lot of thoughts on tiger king
tiger king by the the sixth episode
Carroll bad kid come on we did we could
Pascal taught me to watch it I was like
Tiger king
I got two episodes in I'm like there's
no way this is not I mean I get I get
the fluff and the really factor of it
but I just couldn't
tapped out after time that I had to I
was like listen I'll go I'll do a puzzle
before I'll watch this I watched all of
Tiger King I loved it
totally binge tit yeah I loved it I
don't know if I have any I don't have
any new thoughts that haven't been said
a million times over but I did find the
whole thing a very fascinating character
study we're using webcams here but you
guys look phenomenal I mean you look
beautiful glowy healthy as ever has it
been sweatpants the whole way through or
are you like getting up and putting on
jeans my wife asked me today if I
wondered I'll put the filter on the
camera that would make me look younger
it was like really do I need that thanks
honey
I'm the gym clothes down here I kind of
set up a little tiny gym in my house
with no real weight it's all just bands
and elastics and I don't I don't know if
I'm never gonna go back to the gym are
we looking at your gym is this what I
see but no this I'm in my office but
that is the bike that's my stationary
bike and then I have like a TRX bands
and I have some of the heavy-duty
elastics I got a couple of kettlebells
and some and a few other things and and
I do this workout every second day and
it's it's about three hours oh gosh it's
super yes I know it's super intense I
keep my I do all the the weights and
stuff and then I like in between sets
I'll jump back on the bike and do
two-minute sprint and then off and it's
that's from the beginning like including
the warm-up and the stretching and then
the whole it's about it's about three
hours and that is yeah it's pretty it's
pretty nice
the fans are gonna be upset that we
haven't seen a single post about your
workouts on Instagram
there we go flags are gonna be less
concerned with no work help posts and
the fact that there's no posts period
period Pascale you look beautiful are
you are you doing anything to sort of
you know just yourself are you just kind
of enjoying and doing what I'm doing
which is not getting ready a whole lot
well she's working on Kevin's gonna test
- not getting ready a whole lot but I I
mean I'm doing like I'm not getting
fancy I shower every day well that's a
plus
we think you know I shower every day I
do my skincare routine but just letting
the skin breathe let my hair just it's I
feel like by the end of this I'm gonna
be Rapunzel it's like so long these days
same here my hair so long but uh
exercising a lot much like Kevin I my
friend a very close friend of mine who
also I used to train me before she's now
doing zoom workouts and so she does them
every day and so I just do them every
day and it's like a nice little kind of
touchstone for me that like a 10:00 a.m.
your memory dairy this is what I do
Pascale Aaron had a bone to pick with
you she tried calling you while Hubble
Roundy's were were cooling and you
didn't pick up
hey she's probably asleep I'm gonna go
with that she wouldn't just be screening
my calls I don't think why did you not
answer you know what I wish she had done
a screenshot of her phone just show the
fans when she was calling me it was at
12:30 at night I am NOT receiving baking
tip calls admit night I would have been
more than happy to help her at a
reasonable hour
but 12:30 I need that's my friend much
given that oh so far unless
that those brownies were beyond help and
then she dumps it out and it still looks
like oh yeah and then that first cut in
and it's dough it's raw it's not it's
not Aaron's fault she did everything
correct he knows she's a tricky thing
I'm sorry pan sighs that's not something
I would think about it's important you
should Kevin my question for you
Aaron buckles told et that he's really
trying to grow a beard like his esteemed
co-workers on when calls the heart and
he's just a little bit struggling maybe
one day I'll be able to grow a luscious
full beard like my co-stars yeah because
you don't look at right now but you had
an incredible beard in the last video
that we did with you yeah the beard just
yesterday I nearly two hours ago I
shaved it why'd you get rid of it well I
didn't it wasn't necessarily my
intention my wife suggested that it was
looking a little ratty and she thought
that it was gonna be on et and she likes
the beard she finds it attractive but
she thought it was a little unyielding
so I went upstairs and I had the little
trimmer that I had has like a greater
kind of like clippers and so I put it on
the largest one and I'm like well it's
either a goatee now or nothing see Kevin
that again would have been a brilliant
moment for Instagram so your definition
of Instagram for me is anything
embarrassing cabin can do should be
Instagram now you see like Pascal well
what we see of you on TV is professional
polished you hit your mark you make us
cry you make us laugh on Instagram I
want to see the real cabin and if that
means I don't know
hello there great kid but he has baby
skin he does not have a lot of hair on
his face and you can't grow a beard if
you don't that hair follicles on your
face there's no but he can try and go to
you know a wig place and maybe get a
beard made one of those really patchy
looking things like a merkin a lot of
castes have been getting together
they're doing virtual table reads
they're doing um you know just fun
interactive things with one another to
either bring joy to the audience or to
even raise money for charity is that
something that you guys are having
conversations about as a cast
I definitely talked to the cast about
doing some stuff for charity and fable
reads and everything is he kidding do
you feel excited I got it was like yes
we can tell the Hardys something is it
movement
no you wouldn't helm that probably not
Dever
okay now I'm looking at you and Aaron
yeah yeah we should honestly the
conversation hasn't come up but that
would be a good thing no doubt the
Hardys would love it so that's a great
idea
even if we did instead of a castrate
because we don't have any scripts right
now I mean we can read old script I
guess but we can sit around and do an
open mic night kind of thing would make
me very happy you should do it DJ you
should host it you know I you guys do it
truly be my honor but you know it's up
to you guys in hallmark what you want to
do is as soon as you're ready to pull
the trigger you call me and I would I
would be honored to do anything oh great
well it's fun we did it
[Music]